えまあ見てわかるとおり低評価がとても多いのと
コメント欄が荒れているので
でもコメントを見ても謝罪しろとかねいろいろ批判的なコメントもあるなかでは
はずめ昔からこういうことを知っているから
いいんじゃないのっていうコメントがあって僕も
ある程度荒れるだろうなどをタップするわけなんですけれども
まあとりあえずまず動きがせなきゃいけないのは自分を悪くしてしまった方々本当に
すいませんです
不快にさせたということはやはり事実なのでそこはちゃんと謝っています
でここからですなぜあれ誰かをちょっとさんと
年をさせたいと思っております難しいんだよねコメントのは見つつなんかとあそうな
みんなケンカはやめて俺はただ従っていた
それは里いいと勝手に火油もったいないといった人がその人に対してはじめの自由だ
からいいだろねーさんにそのいいだろという程度に対してバカじゃねーのみたいな俺
じゃないあそれが起きているのに対しておれば良いたよ
いろんな意見があるからですに
僕を悪く言ってもいいしいいねって言ってくれたの僕はもう
歓迎してるんだからその自分の意見を言った人に対して何かコメントで攻撃するのは
おかしいなっていうことを言いたかった
こんなにこれが一番好きならコメント disc 4これで肌は割れなくてもコメント
欄を開いてしまいました
あの僕の動画なんですけどもたぶん昔から見てる人ならわかると思うんですけど結構
その
大量に物を買ったり僕は目的がちゃんとあってやってるから個人的には無駄遣いと思っ
てない理由
それがしたいかリビアでお風呂を作りたいから利便をたくさん買って作ったって言うし
たいことがちゃんとできてるからいろんな見方がある中でですね僕はやっぱ動画でその
ものをたくさん買って使うっていうことが
最近はあんまりしてなかったんですけれども昔から数のものをたくさん使ってね
ただ郊外はニベアクリームに関してはさっきも話していたんだけど
コーラでフルを作った時より低評価が多くて批判的なコメントが多くてこれはなぜかと
いう話ですよね
女家だわ
見てくれてる人が多くなったっていうの
確かになんかやっぱ子供たちの身にも尽くしいろんな影響力があるんですけども僕は
それでスタンスを変えようとも思わないし
それで回釣られたまた何か始め変わったなってなるんでそれについてもね話つをそれを
果たせた周りに合わせちゃうとず分がなくなっちゃう
ダズは変えようとは思ってないんですけど難しい所ですよ何が
悪いのかみたいなあんまないねコメント2
何が悪かったかもこの動画のね
でも多分その二部屋ニベアクリームを1錠的に使っている人からするとその
いつも大切にしているものを
あんな風に投げられると多分
嫌な気持ちにはなるなって思う
食べ物でこういうことしちゃうと荒れるなんていうのはわかる
今回に関しては保湿をするためのクリームでお風呂を作ったわけだから
で僕も保湿をするためにお風呂を作ったわけだから
されございますちょっとよくなって使用用途的には間違ってはないんですけど結果味を
求めているのかというのが気なんです走行なブロー
はあんまりまあよく思わなかった人も言ったけどそんなに
提供かがめちゃくちゃ多かったわけでもないしコーラブルはよくて
リビアクリーム風呂がダメっ
いうその境界線がわからんですも立ち寄ったんですよ
多分
自分がやってみたかったことをやってくれたもうコーラブルは
けどニベアは違うんじゃないあみんなあんまりやりたくなかっ
共感が得られなかったしないな予想外なことをやってそれは思ってもいなかったことを
やったことによって違うじゃないとかそういうのじゃないですか
いうことね
難しい昔からこうしてきたせたまま先を知ってると思うけどほんと初期からなもん
それだけは変わらずにいる多分そこを変えてたら今の自分はないと思ってたんであとは
何かなぁコメント日は
ホワピ傷つくわ
おめバグか口ランこんなことをたたかれることを分かってやってるんだろう
それなのにいざ叩かれたらそんなこと言いやがって前歯から叩かいうのは別に良いです
誰かを叩く来たたコメントに対して誰かが叩いてそれにたて食ってその
連山でしょうコメント内での争いを読みてけっていう意味ですこれは不快に思った人
いると思うんでそこは謝りますちゃんとそこ
申し訳ないですただこの先の話をしないこの先みんながどんな動画が良いと思って
そんなことだけでしたら自分じゃなくなるのは難しい
今た自分が思っていることを言えばいいんじゃないですか
確かにねっ
これは
もやりたいことをやるだけです特に
無理して面白いことをしようとするチャンネルでもないし生んだしたいと思ったことを
やるだけのチャンネルなんだよ
それを貫いてきたけどそうですねそれが例え面白くても面白くなくてもそれをやって
満足してるのは自分なんだよそこは変わらないですね
今後考えていかなきゃいけないことっていうのは
あれですやっぱ永長ですそこはやっぱりアシスト意見のところと
持っていますこれ招いてる人いないと思うん
急遽そのやりたいと思って行動に移るのにも時間かかったして僕もいろいろ考えて動い
ってこういうことになっている影響を考えるとこういうことも出来なくなるのかな
で結論に至るとこういうことをしなくなったはじめ冊を見てガスから見ている人は
変わったねって言ってくるから
僕はどうすればいいのっていう
感じで裾が一つの壁かもしれな
この先俺がステップアップできるかできないか
昔行っても叩かれなかったんですいいぞもっとやれみたい
うわぁ1ニーズはじめ凄い凄いばからすごいあパターン
未だたその影響力とかマークし色んな人が見ちゃうからね厳しい評価が多くなってそれ
にご賛同する人もいうからどうすればいい
僕じゃん多いには変わらずに
ていくのがいいんじゃないかなっていうのはまあ動く昔から見せたんで
ありがとう弓があるっちゃ夢があることをしているしみんなが保存ではいないけどそう
いうことをして自分を楽しんでいる
3楽しいっていうふうにもいればそれでいいんじゃないですか
うんが楽しめれば
環境についておき環境に悪いですよ関係がある意味だそんなにいって思ってるけど体に
塗ってる時点で多分そんな
町外のあるものではないと思うけども200系を調べてみようぜ環境
今回に日あるクリーミーなフローやなかったティディベアクリームわーこの会社によっ
てどんどん製造される訳だからねまあし
ヘアクリームを政府が止まるわけですね日は最強神話やサニークリームなんだよ
それはわかってるやってるいいお風呂ができるぞ
難しいなあこの先どうすればいいだろうっていう花がしていいんだろう
玩具ができることができますそう最終的に商品紹介外ですねはじめ観的には今後どうし
てるんですからこれを機に year
決着なんだろ見てる人が見てって喜んでくれる人が多ければよほど嬉しいからねやって
人が多かったら考える自分は変わってないけど
周りが変わったなって思っ
すごく見てる人と見た場合が変わった墨汁でも多くを作った介護800円のところも付
です
それがここまで来て日られるとなるとどっちには責任というか safari の考え
だけだと思います
影響力大人がし今崎者介助もなるし
医学生の会で好きなことだけやっていくわけには
行かないのかなと好きなことで自宅は買えないけど実験が行われないように好きなこと
でいうアマゾンではないんですけどちゃんと動画だして丸いことは全部
マミーが起こってくれるもう一回あんたそれはない今回のにもうちょっと怒られたら
ちょっと悪いことは自分でもわかってますよねっ
なんか金に頭おかしい人みたいに思ってる
となるかもしれないですけど一応善悪の判断は彼の地でまだ残っています
結論で言うと今度はちゃんと謝ります不快に思った人もいるし
ダメだって思った人もいるけどこれこの動画形相とは思わないです
多分評価道もわかると思うしダメな動画でした結果的に見る人からすると思ったこの
評価を見てこの部分を見た人はダメな事なんだってわかるからこんなたたかれることを
真似する人を見たいと思う
宮國まぁ失敗でしたでここからなんですけども真面目な話するオレを初めて見たんです
よね
やっぱり話すよ
村回ってないところでねソース仁氏口になる可能性もの大量狩り
したいときはします
そこは譲れません僕のしたいことそして山分
なのでこれは評価みるとわかるけど高評価をしている人がゼロではないというのもあっ
てなんか全員が全員某全員が賛成の動画もないし運が反対の動画もないんでね多分
たし
難しいところで大量買いを止めた後でそしたらそしたでなんかつまんないなって思う人
は結局
まぁ出てきちゃうかもしれないはじめ過去の記事しだしたら無くなっちゃう肇社長は
たくなっちゃう改良が入っ
しなきゃと思ってるわけじゃないですよ出したいと思ったらしますし
ただ今回のこれを踏まえてしないってなると昔の火事の一つの方が面白かった始め
変わったと関わらないものはないんですけどスタンスは書いてあげないか
今は
どうすればいいですか皆さん
魔女た部分
どうしてほしい9ないと思うといけないんでそのいきなりやる動画が見直し
広がっているわけだからいやー難しいね本当に
例えば低評価をまったく出されたくないとしたらいちいち毎回ツイッターで今度こう
いうとかやろうと思いましたけど
ロスえーっ
次これやる変だよ痛いそれで起こっ違うんだよ
それじゃないかも自分の動画じゃなくなっちゃう見てくださる方
いる限り
僕はしたいことになります変わらずによっぽどその犯罪とかさーあずに危ないとかそう
いうのはしないよう今までも知ってないと思ってるし
いうある程度ボーダーライン守りつつ
これからもしたいことをやろうと思っています
スイートやめろと架空のかっ
んでもそんな事言ってると南郷的ないってユーチューバー何も出来なくなるから
やっぱなんだろうねメール側のスタンスとしても日常だったら youtube に
分ける必要がないかああべ程度コーヒー地上というかあぁこのチャンネルの動画って
here to の動画だ
でも多分
ここまで聞けないと思う
鮫ちゃんですよね連れが普通のことそれチャンネルではありませんここはそんなことを
するチャンネルではないので過激なこともありますが犯罪とかね
法に触れるようなことはしないし今後もねニベアクリームなその
僕の中で批判もあると思ってた中で行ったんでちょっとグレーゾーンなところはねまあ
自分の中で考えながらこれからやっていこうと思いますすぐに食べ物や命を粗末にして
いるわけじゃないからセーフだと思うけどそんなにでぃべあがにベアがあって騒ぐこと
身体的なが作りたいことあるリビアうブロー行った人に対しぶっちゃけ
2秒プランに関しては何も悪くないんだと思っちゃうけどもし何か本来の用途と違う
って言うんだったらこれの街で会った女用とってもうがねぇ
買った人が決めていいと思う所有者がその人だから中にベアが提供してくれたんだっ
たら
だったそんなでもちゃんとでるよかね私それだけだよねうんそういう意味なんで言っ
ってほとんどの方が速くなるとそれがもし気に食わなかったら見ないっていう選択肢が
ちゃんとあるし
youtube だとまぁ今回はあまり皆さんにとって良くなかった動画という話で
ございます
以後何に気をつければいい
やり方前ていくのが一番いいんじゃない
そうでこれが今まで何してきたって話なんだからこういうこういう動画楽しみにして
ますか
自分ができないことをやってくれてるっていうのがユーチューバー一つの定義でも体
っていうわけではないけど以上的なことをやるから面白い
かといって何か真に必要なことしかしませんってはけどねもう姫っ
音何度も言って申し訳ないんですけども何度もいい
汗が謝りますいませんでしたでまぁ今後なんですけども今回のこの結果を踏まえて僕が
やりたいと思っていることと皆さんがやってほしいと思っていることが一致することは
確実にぴったりつくがないと思ってるんで
皆さんが不快に思うことがあるかもしれませんけど僕はそこはね気をつけていこうとは
思いつつも
下の子は変えずこの先やっていこうと
思っておりますいろいろ心配してくださる方もいたのでちゃんと言っていこうと思って
今回こういう形をとっておりますこれからもいろんな道があると思いますが悪い動画も
いい動画も含めて弾みさちょうだと思ってるんでこれからもねまぁ暇な時にゆるく見る
ぐらいで結構なのでまたよろしくお願いします
みなさんまた次回の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃん
じゃあ鍋いいのかなじゃないいいよねすよ